Your mint-o-phone is ringing.
Pick it up.
Pick up your mint-o-phone.
Your mint-o-phone is ringing.
Blalalalalalalalalala.
Wrong number.
Beep.
Welcome back, master.
If I sound stuffy...
Because I am.
I'm cold.
Thank you.
Hello?
I'm a ghost.
I have a cold.
Not another travel cold.
I can't stop getting sick.
Actually, I told Sakana.
I was just like...
Hey man, I'm sick again.
And he was just like...
He was like...
How did that happen?
And I'm like...
Thank you.
I'm a Vtuber.
I have poor body constitution.
Good performance.
The first opening anime is Kobayashi's Dragon Maverick.
Great and cute.
You did such a great job.
Thank you.
You have a bad connection.
Sakana is built like a pig.
Damn.
Damn, Leo.
Oh my god.
So I...
Oh my gosh.
Leo was there too.
I was gonna say I.
But we.
I mean, I wasn't just...
It wasn't just she and I.
It was...
It was all of us.
We did a concert.
Yippee.
Today's stream isn't gonna be...
Super duper long.
Because I probably need to rest a little bit more.
But...
Yeah.
Did you guys see it?
I have some video of the concert.
Like from the audience.
So if you were there.
You will recognize it.
And if you only got to watch through the...
Through the live stream.
You'll be able to see what the audience was like too.
You kinda sound sick.
Yeah, I'm sick.
I'm sick.
Yeah, I'm sick again.
I can't stop getting sick.
Even Matara was like, how'd this happen?
And I was like, I don't know.
I don't...
I just don't touch grass.
Miralette, thank you so much for the pic.
It was cool seeing Chibi Minto on stage with the face.
Girls, I hope you get over your cold soon.
Thank you.
It's so funny too.
Because when I'm in Japan.
I'm always...
What's the word?
I have the most vitamins that I have usually throughout like the whole year.
All the fans are so cool.
Oh my gosh.
Anthony.
Sakana sent me like a picture of you.
He sent me a picture and was just like, hey, it's this guy again.
He got your...
Your...
Your pull in the gacha.
And I was just like, oh, it's Anthony.
And he was like...
He was like, is that Solid Snake's name?
And I was like, no.
Sakana.
That's Solid Snake.
He was like, oh, okay.
Solid Anthony.
ZZ, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Getting a cold after such a stressful event is such a relatable day.
I know.
I think I like stressed myself out to it for real.
And Solvin, thank you so much for the alcohol.
Watching you sing and dance yesterday was so great.
I can really feel how much you've been putting into your dancing especially.
I always love your singing.
Your dancing was so good.
I absolutely need a full 3D Minto concert.
Thank you.
I...
I put out a tweet earlier actually of like...
And it actually has nothing to do with the concert itself.
It's just that the timing for things that I'm planning and then the finishing of the concert just sort of aligned perfectly.
But hopefully one day I get to have full 3D.
So sorry if I kind of...
We were joking.
I was like, I kind of look like a mascot.
Like when we were like doing rehearsal and stuff.
I was like...
Minto-dayo.
Like Miku-dayo, you know?
But instead I was like Minto-dayo.
You gotta live more filthy to get that immune system built.
I think my brain's got that perfectly down.
Bye, Anaro.
Thanks for the five crypto.
Thank you.
But...
So...
It was so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
Security was not ready for the power of Hamtaro.
That was such an incredible moment.
I can't wait...
Oh my gosh, I have video of it.
I can't wait to show.
But I want to talk like a little bit first.
Or maybe I should like show video and then talk.
Basically, I performed three songs.
I started with Fansa.
And then I did Aozora no Rhapsody.
Which is the...
Maid Dragon.
The Kobayashi Maid Dragon opening.
And then I finished...
We did encore.
All of us.
And I was singing the Hamtaro.
And...
You know...
I...
I don't know if I ever mentioned this before.
But when...
I was asked to join this concert.
I didn't think that I would be it.
The only...
Guest.
I was...
I basically...
I was just like...
Oh...
They were like...
Do you want to be a part of this concert?
As a guest.
And I was like...
Sure.
And then I was like...
Wait, I'm the only guest.
Special guest.
I thought maybe there would be...
Some other people there.
So it ended up being...
FaZe Connect plus Mint.
So it was kind of...
It was kind of funny.
But...
Everybody was so nice.
And...
Oh...
Like I...
Here, hold on.
I kind of blurred out some parts.
Because I wasn't sure if...
Oh wait, I forgot to save it.
I wasn't sure if like...
The bento box would...
Give any sort of location stuff away.
Um...
Hold on, hold on.
This is so cute.
When we went to like...
See the spawn people and everything.
And they gave us...
Like little onigiri and stuff.
And it says...
Welcome to Japan.
This is onigiri rice ball.
And I was like...
That's so cute.
And then like...
Feel free to eat if you like.
And it was so sweet.
And I was like...
Aw, it's so cute.
I had to take a picture.
And then on the left...
The big black thing...
Like I said, it's a...
It's a chicken bento.
But I didn't know if the...
Location of it...
Was kind of like...
You know...
Like would give away any sort of locations.
Or like, you know...
The look of it...
Would give away any sort of location stuff or whatever.
So um...
Yeah!
They prepared that for us.
It was really cute.
Thank you for all the super chats, you guys!
See you next time!
Thank you for the wonderful performance.
It made me so happy to see you that I cried.
No!
KT!
Don't cry!
Bento was the special guest.
It was me, the special guest.
Jelly filled donuts.
I know.
Trust me, I thought about it.
I was just like...
Oh my gosh!
They had jelly doughnuts!
But yeah.
I recognize that chicken.
You know what I mean!
Like if you were a chicken, you would be like...
If someone recognizes the outside of the bento, you know it was all wrapped up, okay?
I'm just being safe.
Being there in person was truly an enchanting experience, especially with other Wisps and Faves fans.
Hope you enjoyed our Wotagei shenanigans.
I did!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Manatee, thank you for the dead gift!
Thank you!
Hold on, I have to drink some water.
The medicine here that, like, they have in Japan...
Like, when they're just like, hey, you want to stop your runny nose?
It dries everything.
Like, my whole mouth becomes so dry.
But my nose is still congested!
Yes, I've been taking my meds.
But yeah...
Can't wait for Mint's solo concert.
Oh my gosh.
That would be the day, huh?
No, I...
I was very, you know, very honored to be invited to this.
And, you know, honestly, like, when going indie, I was like...
I was like...
You know, when going indie, I was like, will I ever have an opportunity, you know, to do something like this?
So, you know, the fact that it came, and also came so soon...
I was like, I wish I had had a full 3D prepared, but...
Unfortunately, I had to hold off 3D stuff.
And it was all kind of last minute, too.
They, like, asked...
They were like, do you want to join?
I was like, sure!
And they were like, okay, we're booking everything now!
We need everything now!
Get us everything now!
And I was like...
But I was like...
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, my throat is so sore now that I'm talking.
I mean, not sore, dry.
But I was like, you know...
I was like...
What was I saying?
Oh!
I was like, well, it's 3D...
So...
I should sing songs that, like...
I can really move around in.
And so...
You know, I chose FANZA because I thought that was a song...
I always...
I sing FANZA a lot at concerts because I feel like it's a song that...
A lot of people know.
Very easy to do calls, too.
And so...
I'm always thinking of calls.
When I pick my setlist...
My water brain just...
It's just like...
What songs can you do the most with the gate to?
So...
I picked that.
And then...
And then for...
I was on a Rhapsody.
It's a very special song to me as well.
And I was like...
Well, I can actually, like...
Kind of do the dance to it.
You know?
Because...
I will be in 3D.
So...
Um...
I thought you sang FANZA because it's fancy.
No!
FANZA stands for fan service.
It's about like an idol giving fan service during...
You know...
Being...
She's just like...
Fan service to the fans.
But...
Yeah.
And then...
Um...
And then, of course, Hamtaro.
Which is like...
So...
Which is so...
Like...
So fun.
I wasn't actually sure if people would be able to...
Run around...
At all.
But I was just like...
Of course, you can at least do the calls.
But then when I saw that people were running around too...
I was just like...
No way!
It's happening!
The Hamtaro circle!
And it was so big!
It was an amazing experience to share with Wisps and others.
Being able to participate in a Hamtaro circle is a dream come true!
I'm so happy!
Cause like...
I have so many...
So many...
And like...
You know...
Hamtaro is not a very long song.
So I was like...
Maybe...
It's not the best song to sing at a concert.
But whatever.
Whatever.
And um...
Uh...
But...
Um...
What was I saying?
Oh gosh, sorry.
The concert was so amazing!
Thank you, Pinto!
Thank you!
I was...
Oh!
Yes!
I remember what I was saying.
I have so...
So many memories of doing Hamtaro.
But like...
It would be like a friend...
A friend group of like...
10...
15 of us.
You know?
Like...
I've never in my...
Ever...
You know...
Only in my dreams would I imagine doing such a...
Such a big...
Huge...
Hamtaro circle with so many people!
So...
Even for me, it was a dream come true.
Oh my gosh!
I was like...
No way!
It's so huge!
It was so much fun!
We even sucked some staff into the Hamtaro circle.
Let's go!
I have...
I have footage of it that I'll...
That I'll be showing you guys.
Because...
It's so...
Oh my gosh.
I literally have not been able to stop smiling or thinking about it because it's just...
And...
I've just been really happy that...
Like I said...
Like going indie.
I'm not sure if these kinds of opportunities will come, but...
And...
Oh gosh, I'm extra stuffed.
Oh my gosh.
I know that the timing was kind of hard too because...
It kind of was like back to back with...
Breaking Dimensions, but...
Still so many people showed up.
So...
YouTuber fans were eating good this weekend, huh?
Mucus.
Yeah, I'm full of it.
I'm full of so much mucus.
But...
It was so funny actually.
So actually...
One of the...
So for...
We had to record some of the...
So I recorded you know like the backing vocals for...
Aozora No Rhapsody.
Actually... it was so embarrassing.
Because, oh my gosh, did you guys know?
Okay, so we get through all of the ad-libs, no, not ad-libs, all of the, you know...
Just those parts and the songs and the choo-choo yeahs and everything like that.
And we get to one last part of the chorus, you know, like there's little parts that they say in the backgrounds of the chorus.
And the sound guy in the studio, he's just like, okay, now it's this last one.
Hold on, let me look up the lyrics real quick.
So I don't mess up exactly what they say.
Like, yeah, they'll say like, please stay with me.
Or, nante tate, congratulations.
Things like that.
And...
The last one that I had to record was the guy, was the sound guy.
He was Japanese, obviously, we recorded it in Japan.
And he was just like, okay, for the last one is...
Make me rhapsodic.
And I was like, huh?
I was like, what?
And he was just like, yeah, make me rhapsodic.
And I was like, what do you mean?
And it's not even like...
It's like...
So we had to explain to him...
That I was basically like singing this bad word.
And it goes up really high and I have to hold it.
So I'm just like...
Make me rhapsodic.
And I'm just like...
I'm like shouting dick in the sound booth.
And I'm like, no!
I could barely get through it.
And I had to keep repeating it over and over again.
I was like, this is not even a real word.
This is not even a...
I don't...
Is it a real word?
Actually, I don't even know.
Rhapsodic.
Oh, maybe it is.
Wait, it's a book.
What is the meaning of rhapsodic?
Extravagantly enthusiastic.
Ecstatic.
Why couldn't they say make me enthusiastic instead?
I get that it's Aozora no Rhapsody.
I think it's rhapsodic.
Like emphasis on the soul.
Yeah, but that's not how it goes in the song.
Hahaha.
Oh, rhapsod...
Rhapsodic.
Yeah, but in the song, they say rhapsodic.
They're just like, make me so rhapsodic.
That's how it goes in the song.
So you can blame Fana.
Not, not, ugh, Fana.
But Fana the band.
Oh my gosh.
You did an amazing job performing on stage.
I'm so glad to see you sing your heart out up there.
Thank you.
I love you too.
Too.
Basically, Mint played the pee-pee game by herself.
But instead of shouting pee-pee, it's...
No!
Is that a noun or an adjective?
It says it's an adjective.
Rhapsodic.
Rhapsodic?
Hahaha.
Yeah, so that was really embarrassing.
And I'm just like, I'm like singing it.
And I'm just like staring up at the ceiling trying to avoid any eye contact from everybody in the studio.
And I look over and everybody's just like, like they're all like giggling at me.
And I'm just like, I hate this.
I hate this.
But another thing that I recorded was...
I actually also recorded the Hamtaro.
Because what I wanted to do was...
I wanted to do the calls live.
So I actually recorded me singing it.
And then the calls were done live for the show.
So kind of the opposite.
I got to have my own little WOTA moment too.
But I remember we had a...
I record things with a vibe gifted.
It's like episodic.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
But still, why?
But...
What was I saying?
Yeah.
Oh, so I recorded that.
And we had the translator guy.
We had a guy who was helping us translate.
And...
After I...
I did Hamtaro in one take.
And I was just like, yeah baby.
Let's go.
They were like, that's good.
One take.
Easy done.
And afterwards...
The translator, he was just like...
It was so good, actually.
You sounded exactly like a kindergartner.
I was like, what do you mean by that?
He was just like, your pronunciation, you know?
And the way that you sang it and stuff.
Sounded very good, like a kindergartner.
I was like, are you saying that?
I was like, what?
What?
What pronunciation?
He was like, the way you were pronouncing it.
You know, you made it sound like a kindergartner.
I was like, that's just how I...
That's just how I talk, sir.
And he was like, ah.
Well, it fit the song.
I was like, I didn't...
I didn't add anything special to it.
I'll never forget this weekend.
Thank you, Min.
Thank you, Kiriha.
Oh, you take those.
That was the first VTuber concert I've been to.
And it was a lot of fun.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, Min.
Couldn't think of a better way to end my time at Anime NYC.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It means a lot.
So, let's watch some video from the concert as well.
Because, let's see.
I don't want to start with the Hamtaro.
I have some other things out here.
I'm going to pause the music real quick.
And...
Let's see.
What do I want to start with?
Let's start with Fine Sound because that's what I started with too.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I have some other stuff that I want to...
Hold on.
Let's start with this.
Okay.
Let me know if it's too loud or...
Hold on.
Actually.
One second.
I'm scared.
I'm scared it's going to be really loud.
If it's too loud, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, I was like...
Oh, my gosh.
We have this whole stage, right?
I was like, I need to...
Like, it was...
You know, my first time...
Having such a big stage before.
And I was like, oh, I want to like fill up the whole stage.
I want to make sure the people on the left can see me.
I want to make sure the people on the right can see me.
I want to make sure everybody can see me.
So, I was just like dashing.
I was mad dashing side to side.
I was like...
And the poor cameraman is like also trying to keep up with my freak.
He's just like unable to...
He's
like unable to keep up with me because I'm like literally all over the place.
I was like, I got to make sure everybody can see me.
I was just so excited.
Okay.
And then I was just like, okay, I should probably tone this down for Aozora Rhapsody.
The guy, the cameraman was just like...
He looked a little...
He looked a little tired.
So, but I was just like, I just want to make sure everybody can see.
But now, looking at it now, I look like...
I'm like a creature.
I'm like a cretin like running from...
Why am I so dramatic?
Look at the way I run.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting such secondhand embarrassment.
Look at this.
Oh, I don't...
Okay, sorry.
I was so like...
Hold on.
Oh, you could see it here, really.
Oh, where did the music go?
There we go.
I'm like, mad dashing over there.
I like, I ran, ran.
I was not even like dancing, running.
I was like...
And in the TV, it looks even weirder.
It's so fun.
Look!
Cyclone!
Naisu!
Yeah, so fun.
I don't know who took this video.
Yay!
So I start with...
Kindergarten running...
Stop!
This is so funny.
I was like...
Oh goodness.
Running man, would have been proud of you.
Oh my gosh, cameraman!
Yeah, thanks a lot.
Getting your steps in that day, cameraman!
So yeah, I did fine so...
And then I...
I had a...
I was on a Rhapsody.
Okay, okay.
I have a problem.
I have a bone to pick with you guys.
I have a real bone to pick with you guys.
What the hell... Hold on, I'm gonna mute it real quick.
What the hell is this ketcha?
What the hell are you guys doing?
Why are you ketcha-ing?
DURING THE CHORUS?!
DID YOU LEARN NOTHING?!
Hold on.
Oh, where did the music go?
This is not a ketcha moment!
Who allowed this?!
JoJo!
DID YOU LEARN NOTHING?!
Oh my gosh.
What a gay lessons win.
I swear, you guys.
I swear!
She hates us.
Just... just...
We're still new.
This is not ketcha!
This is not... this is not when you do ketcha.
This is when you are excited to bull.
And everything!
No ketcha!
No ketcha here!
It is chorus!
It is excitable chorus!
Why is that?
Why are you guys acting like it's a slow part?
There's... I... I don't understand.
Who... who... who... who led this?
Who led this?
We need what a gay lessons stat.
We're learning, okay?
We need what a gay lessons stat!
That!
I meant... I don't have a voice anymore because of the concert.
But that's okay because mixing the FANZA for you is the highlight of my year.
Thanks, Ashes!
But yeah.
Yeah, I tried to like fill the whole stage.
But it was really big.
Confused but they got the spirit.
Our section was doing the footy copy.
Nice!
I think we were doing something, right?
Yeah, footy copy is okay.
Fairy under the desk said to...
The fairy would never say that.
We need more lessons.
Okay.
Well, I'll give you guys some what a gay lessons, you know?
Okay?
Okay.
No idea what I'm doing with the pen line.
She hates us, Kouru.
It was fun.
Ah, I have that too!
There is a video.
Look at this.
This is the encore.
I have actually two...
I have two versions of it.
I have this one first.
This is the one Sakana sent to me.
She hates us.
It's so loud!
It's so perfect!
Oh my god!
Why is this the encore all the time?
Why is this the encore?
At least you guys were in sync, right?
Good encore, everybody.
Good job.
That, I'm proud of you.
Very proud.
You're very in sync.
Very in sync.
Yes, yes.
Very good, very good.
And then...
And then we did...
I have a couple of...
Oh, I have my MC!
I forgot...
Oh, this one too.
Wait.
Wait, I think I forgot to download a video.
I'll download it after.
But this one...
This is after...
Aozora Rhapsody.
How do you like the cult you raised me to?
I was one who started the She Hates Us chant instead of an encore.
My B, I didn't think it would catch on.
No!
Why are you saying my B?
It's so funny!
It was the blast of a concert.
You and the other wits made it unforgettable for me.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh, wait.
My chat got weird.
Hold on.
Xenaph, thanks for the donut too.
Yeah, Gezor, thank you so much!
Hi!
Thank you, thank you!
I went to the concert yesterday.
You and everyone did great.
It was nice to talk to other wisps while waiting in line.
Yeah!
I'm so happy!
Thank you, thank you!
And then, oh yeah.
This was after Aozora Rhapsody.
I'm so loud.
Hold on.
Okay, this part too.
Okay, so I go this side.
Yeah!
This side!
And then, you guys...
I was so...
I was so flustered.
I forgot to say the middle!
I was so like...
I forgot to do the middle!
So I only did one side.
And then the other side.
I forgot to say the middle.
I'm sorry!
Oh my gosh!
Did you guys have fun?
Yeah!
Look at all the mint pen lights!
It looks so good!
It's so pretty!
Oh my gosh!
I'm very honored to have been...
And then it cuts off.
Cameraman hates MC.
Oh gosh!
I can't believe I forgot!
Look at this!
Everyone in the middle waiting for their choice.
For their...
For their chance to cheer.
Oh my gosh!
And I just forget!
The
middle!
Anybody seen it in the middle?
They're all just like...
Okay!
There's one guy who's probably just like...
Sorry, I'm really snotty.
He's got his hands up.
He's got his pen lights.
He's just like...
Oh boy!
She's gonna say the middle next!
And that'll be me!
And then I'll cheer too!
And I'll be part of the crowd!
And I just...
I just never...
I'm so sorry.
Next time I'll give extra, extra love to the middle.
I'm sorry.
Next time I'll give extra love to the middle.
Legend has it the middle election is still waiting for you.
I'm sorry.
Yay!
See you got to cheer there!
Yeah!
That guy's waving his hand really high.
But then...
Oh wait.
I think I mislabeled this as Hamtaro.
Oh no, just kidding.
Wait, where is my Hamtaro?
Okay, hold on.
I forgot to save a video.
But I don't remember which one it is.
Uh...
One second.
Where was it?
Hold on.
Which one is it?
Oh, I think it's... hold on.
This one.
I think.
Hold on, let me double check this.
Sorry.
Did I show this one?
I can't remember what I've shown or not.
Oh, wait.
There was more fun stuff.
Wait, I didn't watch this one.
Oh, I forgot to show this one too.
Hold on you guys.
I forgot two whole videos.
Keep the crowd on their toes.
Yeah, you'll never know when I'm gonna call on you.
I could call just the left side one time.
I could call just the right side sometime.
I could call the back.
I could call the front.
You never know.
Running around for Hamtaro was not what I was expecting from this concert.
Well, get used to it, baby.
Because that's just...
That's just how Minto concerts go.
Minto concerts are all about that fun.
This is, you know, I always, you know, I love idols.
And I love Wotage so much.
And I always have wanted to kind of share all of that with you guys too.
Especially for people who have never experienced like any kura or any idol kind of stuff before.
So...
You know, when people are just like, Oh my gosh, I got to do a Hamtaro circle.
And it was like so crazy and so fun.
Because it's such like a...
It's such a unifying experience.
Especially when a group of people are just able to to like come together and do calls.
At the same time, it's like such a...
Such an electric feeling.
You know?
And so I've always wanted to really, really share that with people.
So...
You know...
The fact that it's spread so much is...
Oh my gosh, it's like the best thing.
It's so much fun.
And you know, people are still learning.
And people are still trying to get the hang of it.
But, you know...
Once you...
Once you get the basics down and...
Like...
Can really kind of get a feel for things.
How to do things.
You can apply it to like any song.
It's great.
Real men are born in the Hamtaro circle.
So true.
Thanks for making this weekend unforgettable.
Cheered my heart out at the concert and joined the Hamtaro circle.
Yeah!
So happy.
Here, hold on.
I have some other...
Before I show the Hamtaro circle.
Um...
This one's a fan song also.
Oh.
Oh, the beginning of the fan song.
Wait, wait, wait.
What was that?
Minto.
Oh, really.
Did you guys say, Are no Minto?
I twirled!
Oh!
Hi!
Good job, good job!
Oh, my gosh, you guys have PPVH!
Good job!
Good job, good job!
We were yelling calls in the back.
That's usually... Okay...
Because they know the calls best, but... and this is probably just mostly with like chika idols and idols in Japan, like underground idols in Japan, but the fans in the back are where it's all at, baby.
That's where like the... that's where all the hype and the party is at.
So, you know, it's the... it's always the... it's always the back.
That's... I used to want to be in the front because I'm like, oh my gosh, I'll be so close to my idols, but when you become like a fan for so long, you're just like, nah, the back is where you gotta...
So that call you heard, it was definitely a normal ore no minto, nothing else.
What was it?
What did you say?
So my first time going to a VTuber concert, doing calls, oh my gosh, thank you very much!
August said, me and my wallet cry tears of joy, then why are you super chatting?
Oh my gosh, but thank you.
Ore no white girl?
What?
No way.
I'm listening.
Oh my god, I hear it.
No, white girl, stop!
Wait, does that actually hit?
I hate you guys.
You know what?
She hates us?
It's real.
This is also my first VTuber concert.
Oh my gosh, no way.
Thank you.
I'm honored to be so many people.
I'm honored to be so many people's first VTuber concert, seriously.
She hates us.
Hi, she hates us.
Real.
She hates us.
Ore no white girl.
Oh my gosh, but then of course, I have to show the Hamtaro.
So this one, oh my god, hold on.
It's, oh my gosh, it's so great.
It's so good.
Look at this.
This is such a highlight for me.
There is a.
I'm a person who is talking about something rather than me.
Oh my gosh.
Do you have to ride like me?
You're a human being.
I'm a human being.
Yeah, you're like me.
I'm also like me.
I'm also like me, too.
I'm
like you and I'm also like me.
So how do we do this?
I'm like a human being.
I don't understand.
I'm also like you.
I also like you.
I understand.
One, two, three, go!
There are so many people!
Oh my god!
That's so...
I could not understand the scale until this video.
Until I was sent this video.
I did not understand how many people were one, there.
And two, like, participated in the Hamtaro circle.
No wonder security couldn't stop you guys.
This is what I mean by unleash the yakai in your soul.
Hold on, I have another one.
I think this one is another, like, further out video.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh!
Hi!
You can hear everybody so well!
And then I get beat up and I die again.
Yay!
I actually didn't...
I didn't know if they were gonna wake me up or not.
Min's next concert stop is Budokan.
Yeah, right.
But yeah.
Hold on, I wanna watch the Hamtaro again.
I wanna watch the first video again.
It's too good.
Oh, it's so loud.
You can hear the calls better in the...
other video, I think.
Everybody getting their steps in.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
It's so awesome!
There's so many people!
Oh my gosh!
I actually...
So also with this too...
I was like, I really wanna see if I can make...
if I can pull Hamtaro off, you know?
And like, have people go in a circle.
But originally too...
it was just supposed to be like...
an encore song.
But it was only me.
And I was just like...
Well, you know...
I want the other girls to come out too.
And we can all run around in a circle together.
And they were...
They were kinda confused about the...
About what I wanted to do.
I had to like send them...
Anikura videos and be like...
This is...
This is what I want.
And they were like...
Oh!
I was like, all you do is...
run around.
It's...
Because they were like...
Do we wanna do like a choreography?
And I was like...
No.
I just wanna run in a circle.
I was like...
They were like...
They were like sending...
I think like there's choreography from like...
On Stars or something.
And I was like...
No.
Circle.
And so...
I was just like...
Just be silly and goofy.
And do whatever.
You know?
I was just like...
Don't...
No seriousness.
Only...
Only goofy fun.
Your turn to circle.
No choreography.
Only circle.
So...
Yeah.
I'm so...
I'm so happy.
I ended up working out.
I'm so happy that...
It seems like so many people had fun.
I learned the choreo...
The On Stars choreo.
Oh.
Sorry, Lia.
Only circle.
Only circle, Lia.
Sorry, Lia.
Only circle.
Just a circle.
Can you see it?
I have footage of other people, but I didn't want to show just in case they wanted to show it on their end.
Oh my gosh, but everybody was so fun.
Everybody was so good.
Everybody was so cute.
Oh my gosh, Lia's dancing!
When she was doing Darling Dance, I was like dancing along because I also kind of know that dance.
So I was just like dancing along backstage.
I was like...
Oh my gosh, she sounded so good.
She looked so good.
Sorry, I came out.
I felt like, I was like, oh my gosh, I have to fall.
I have to come out after her.
And I'm looking like this blobby chibi mess, you know, after she was so good.
But...
You know.
Sorry that I was a chibi blob.
But Lia's so amazing at dancing, so I'm really glad that she could get 3D and be able to show that off to everybody.
Born idol.
She's idol.
Like, she tweeted that Sakana said to her after he saw her dancing that his idol dream wasn't dead.
But was Faye's ever supposed to be idols?
I wonder.
Biblically accurate chibimento.
With my giant hands and everything.
I feel like I've been chibi for so long at this point.
Going back to normal will be so weird.
You know.
I've been chibi for so long now.
I don't know what it's like.
I don't know what it's like to be normal size.
I died in the made-me-into-eventaro mosh pit.
No!
You're just a ghost just like me now.
Basically.
Sakana's dream is coffee.
I guess so.
I already forgot what you look like.
Me too.
Faye's is mainly a coffee company.
Please understand.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wanna try it.
Ugh, gosh.
Ugh, I'm so congested.
I'm sorry, guys.
You can use the chibi toggle on your normal model.
No.
It's not the same.
Can we order Faye's coffee at your main cafe?
Um...
We'll see.
They're gonna ask for a cut, though.
And, uh...
Made-me-into-cafe is 100% profits for me.
So I can fund my idol addiction.
You know?
So I gotta...
I gotta...
I gotta get money.
So then I can give my money to idols, too.
You know?
So...
Business is business.
What can I say?
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Ugh.
Let me turn the music back on.
You know when you're so congested and it, like, gets stuck in the back of your throat?
And you, like, can't...
get it out of the back of your throat?
That's me right now.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm blowing my nose right now.
I'm like...
Don't mute the music.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Ah.
It feels like you're choking.
Yes!
That's how I feel right now.
Ooh!
Carla Mold!
Idol live funds.
Thank you!
Stop!
No!
Don't fund my addiction!
Thank you.
I was actually supposed to go to an idol thing today that I won.
I, like, won the ticket for it.
And it was supposed to be...
You guys, it was supposed to be making pancakes with my Oshii!
And I couldn't go because I didn't want to get her sick.
But I missed out on making pancakes with my Oshii!
I'm so depressed.
Hahaha.
I even won the ticket.
Ah.
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh, yeah.
For those who weren't able to go to the concert, I hope that the videos kind of showed you a little bit.
Sorry.
I'm choking on my mucus.
Hahaha.
VOD's still available.
Yeah.
The, um...
You can still watch the stream.
Yeah.
The stream doesn't show the audience, though.
So...
Um...
But if you want to see it in full, of course, you can still watch the VOD.
And, um...
I wish it would show the audience.
Maybe next time we can figure out a way to do that.
Um...
Yeah.
Haha.
But it was so much fun.
And I'm just really happy.
Um...
Thank you so much, AnimeMYC and FaZe Connect for having me!
I was...
You know...
Like I said, I was quite surprised to be the only guest, but I was like...
So honored.
I'm so happy.
You're the reason I got to experience the legendary Hamtaro Circle!
Hahaha.
I cried during Fanta.
It made my eye patch itchy.
Hahaha.
Thanks, Anthony!
Thank you so much for the pink!
And, um...
You know...
Um...
I know that it was also during...
Uh...
During the Hololive concerts, it was kind of in between everything as well.
Um...
Uh...
But if you were able to go to both...
I hope you had so much fun!
If you were able to go to just one of them...
Whichever one it was...
I hope you were able to have such a super duper fun time.
And, uh...
Hopefully, um...
I can get more concerts in the future.
Hopefully, I can get more concerts!
I can get concerts that stop overlapping with other concerts!
Or other events!
Hahaha.
But, you know, that tends to happen at such big events like an anime convention.
There's always going to be something that is, uh...
That is, uh...
Overlapping, probably.
But, um...
I don't know.
I think I have just bad luck with this kind of stuff.
Hahaha.
Um...
Bought streaming tickets for both.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
But...
Yeah, I'll keep doing my best so that...
Um...
More events will...
Hopefully see these kinds of videos and be like...
Wow!
This is the maid mint...
Power!
This is her energy!
She can make a whole group of people go into a circle!
Hahaha!
In such a big room!
This is...
With my power!
Hahaha!
The worst part of a stuffy nose is when one nostril is clear and the other one is blocked.
Both of my nostrils are blocked.
Hahaha!
I saw both.
Thanks for an awesome weekend, Mint!
Thank you!
Hahaha!
Yeah.
So...
Um...
I'll keep doing my best.
And, um...
Uh...
Yeah.
If you have a concert...
You want to see me at...
You know...
Just...
Um...
Talk to your...
Or not a concert...
A...
Convention!
Just say...
Hey!
Convention!
Please invite...
Maid Mint.
Though I am trying to kind of slow down a little bit since...
Um...
I think that's why I'm getting sick.
Hahaha!
Because I've been...
Um...
Kind of pushing myself a little bit.
So...
Uh...
Yeah.
Hahaha!
Congrats on the concert, Maid Mint!
I wish I could have seen you in the face, girls.
Especially...
Since it's my birthday today!
Wow!
Solo the Scott!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Solo the Scott!
Happy birthday!
Um...
Maid Mint touring with Limp Bizkit Wood!
Hahaha!
That'd be crazy.
Um...
But yeah!
Thank you guys!
For...
AMYC!
I know this is a shorter stream.
But I gotta...
I gotta pack!
And I...
Because I'm moving hotels soon.
And I also have to sleep.
So that I can recover.
And not be...
A...
Um...
Mucusy mess.
Haha!
Too much ectoplasm.
The concert was legendary!
Went fully Akai!
Hahaha!
My pompadour almost died from trying the other game!
JP!
You and your...
You and your pompadour.
Do you wear that to every con?
You're crazy!
Hahaha!
Wow!
Thank you!
It was great to see you moving around in 3D!
Can't wait to see you dancing in real 3D someday!
Yes!
And when I get my real 3D!
Let's make a really, really big one!
Let's make a big event out of it!
Yeah!
Even though I'm indie!
I will!
Do my best!
To!
Make it!
Really!
Awesome!
Congrats on the concert!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I wear it to every con!
Man!
You're crazy!
Congrats on the concert!
Can't wait to see more!
Thanks Chagi!
Hahaha!
Otsumito guys!
I will see you guys!
Next stream!
Whenever I see you!
Whenever!
Um...
Stay healthy!
Ok?
Hahaha!
Don't be like me!
Otsumito!
Itterashoi!
You can't see but I'm waving at you!
If I were in 3D you'd be able to see!
But you know...
Haha!
Um...
Maybe...
Maybe someday...
Ok!
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thanks for supporting us!
Thank you guys!
Bye!
Wow!